les cherry on va démarrer par miss
alsace miss alsace cécile wolfrom 23 ans
1 m 64 à la la la qui savent allier
alors
pas du tout homogène et on nous a
demandé de faire un top3 clairement elle
est dans le top vous seriez heureuse que
miss alsace soit miss france alors cette
année ces médisants ouais le temps passe
très vite cette année j'ai fait mes dix
ans et c'est clair que si on fête ses
dix ans ce serait magnifique de passer
la relève passer le flambeau et que la
fête se refasse dans ma région ben ouais
ça ne va surveiller heureusement bain
pour les dix ans à le fait sur yon
heureuse que vraiment il ya une nouvelle
miss alsace que vous savez que pour vos
dix ans ça serait génial ce sera un
super cadeau ou payer nouveau la fête
dans ma région et que la région ça ne
vaut mieux vous insistez
ce serait génial non mais sérieux c'est
magnifique c'est à dire mais après s'il
a la même quatre ans mais rêve déjà de
le dire que
l'intervention de mr dans d'une minute
c'est la laver son nikon et voilà alors
s et cl wolfrom miss alsace très belle
on a également miss aquitaine ambre
andrieu 22 ans 1 m 78 étudiante en
dernière année d'ingénierie en physique
chimie
du coup la question c'est est ce qu'on
va faire les hypocrites et dire que non
on doit pas perdre non pas du tout on a
le droit de dire qu'on aime ma grotte
dire on a le droit à de très belles
alors pour l'instant c'est loin d'être
quoi de plus miss alsace ont pu 6005
iten mai salle vasse d'accord miss
alsace qui est alors après il ya miss
auvergne anaïs verte chaque 24 ans m et
77 cents
alors oui ah oui
oui oui a bondi de bayreuth choc il
allie médecins aillent à ce week end ses
normes et ses
magnifiques
il ya miss bourgogne chloé galicie 21
ans 1 m 72 au choix
d'irina un peu serrés vers des rythmes
est assez vrai pas alors miss bourgogne
c'est ce qu'a fait partie de votre
préfet un poisson toujours alsace alsace
nous dit que ça change
on a misé bretagne sarah conan le
barbare
ça a connu cinq ans on dirait une aura
on dirait une aura lumineuse non mais
mignonne la route style de photos c'est
pour ça que c'est dur de juger si c'est
pas
de fossiles non plus pour l'instant
c'est 800 photos natoye miss alsace à
des fossiles bah oui c'est il ya dix ans
on a le droit à sa miss france d'avoir
des possibles pourquoi pas l'élection ah
non pas l'élection a gravé son nom
n'aura pas si sûr si elles sont toutes
voilà c'est sûr si on met des fossiles à
quelqu'un ça ça fait un regard de chat
des lada pour la photo est d'accord donc
là elle aura pas de facile bon d'accord
pas de possibles élections c'est
important de le dire jade l'ange 18 ans
1 m 75 étudiante en licence des sciences
du langage mais les 100000 centre val de
loire mais pour l'instant on regarde
toujours sur miss alsace à volvo des
miss alsace vous remettez miss alsace
voilà
alors est ce qu'il y aurait toujours
des alsaces merci pour l'instant tout le
monde est sur miss alsace miss alsace 1
me champagne ardenne l'ena ma singer
massinga non non si elle est jolie
alors c'est votre cas moi pour moi
pour moi c'est pas mon délire
personne et mon délire savait mais vos
bouquets l'alsace pour partir pour me
champagne ardenne voix jeu bah voila je
non non non non non non voilà mesdames
c'est vous qui décidez brochard bonbons
pas mon mot à dire à l'antique alors
elle est magnifique mais non toujours
miss alsace miss corse emma renucci
regardez ma à
il ya des très belles filles cette année
alors et marraines outils
aux années passées c'est quand même des
photos différentes parties on a souri
des photos vraiment mal prises avec
alors c'est pas les photos fichiers
joly sur les photos officielles parce
que je n'ai pas exactement les photos
officielles est plus joli sur instagram
et c'est la photo de miss alsace elle
est canon lennon armani mais qu on ait
présenté des photos voilà y'a demi et 1
valérie pavlova pav le 1 pavle un bon
coach on y étudie en toiture birmane et
non avec chirurgie dentaire côte d'azur
alors côte d'azur après beaubourg
toujours alsace 20 alsace
moi j'attends la mienne d'accord après
bien d'accord du château le boscq lui
demander d'avoir dérangé
valeria pavle un hall 4 ans elle est
étudiante en 3e année de chirurgie
dentaire
pas beau vous avez en vous allez avoir
envie d'attraper des carriers
[Rires]
ils volent et walery dites moi il ya une
pub mis ces derniers mots de la bouche
mais je vous en mets surtout les
conneries de la mouche à mes copines
elle lutte contre la maltraitance
animale d'accord avec moi comme delphine
et comme vous je lutte contre la
maltraitance animale et contre les
analyses des chroniqueurs qui servent à
rien
julie crétins s'appelle julie crétins
qui n'est alors julie crétins c'est miss
franche-comté pas mal elle femmes et
alsace d'accord toujours admis squad les
plus divine et demi un très belle très
très belle lutte à gramat ouais ouais
ouais ouais ouais très joli ludivine
étudiante en 2e année de comptabilité
gestion très joli port dont moi c'est
les études que j'ai fait ah ouais ouais
ça vous fait un point commun bon bah oui
mais bon s'il y avait des points qu
break tout
[Rires]
non mais sans rigoler complètement
j'étais miss guyane mélissa stephenson
a du caractère ouais c'est vrai elle est
étudiante en deuxième année de
sociologie et on boit du lait de
marketing digital ce que j'ai fait aussi
j'ai fait j'ai tout fait oui toujours
prometteuse grâce à chaque fois comme
cella gagnant la vague bas mettez alsace
d'un côté voilà pour l'instant x 106
vraiment michel de miss ile de france
diane l'air
agents immobiliers elle est agent
immobilier
est allé dans la région ile-de-france a
que je sais que vous visitez son monde
et apparaît à l'écouter on va pas tarder
à le voir chez laforêt sida
alors pour l'instant quelqu'un soit -
île-de-france je la trouve magnifique
elle a du chien en fait comme aurait dit
c'est ça hein miss languedoc roussillon
marion ratier 20 ans étudiante en 3e
année de classe préparatoire diplôme de
comptabilité gestion qui décidément font
tout à oui oui oui oui à moi moi c'est
pas mon délire mais vous
rassure l alsace s'accordent auxquels
ces miss languedoc roussillon vous
retiendrez la région languedoc
roussillon merci miss ou miss limousin
julie belle hôtesse de l'air ne
fait pas mieux en france mais elle fait
actrice et mais oui voilà j'aime bien la
comédienne julie baby miss limousin on
se dit quoi alsace
si vous nous rejoignez les complètement
fou la miss lorraine marine sauvage ah
oui comme l'autre paulette ouais non
comme le col est jolie oui elle est
naturelle elle est nature elle est
nature peinture elle est étudiante en
cinquième année de pharmacie et voilà m
miss lorraine dans toujours alsace
alsace à d'acquérir le fils de fond
pagne de marine le pen merci
merci très bonne internationalis
martinique floriane bascou floriane
bascou l'échelle est chouchouté puis
elle vient de se marier
des photos de robes de mariée c'est
l'effondrement de mal à battre est bien
mac revient pas très bien alors donc
belle miss martinique miss mayotte anna
housni 24 ans
diplômée d'un bachelor responsable de
zone import export et ça c'est important
de l'avoir ce bachelor alors c'est vrai
on aime bien ancrée alors pas de chasse
c'est toujours toujours
d'accord ah non alors anna friconnet
miss midi-pyrénées 22 ans étudiante au
collège
[Applaudissements]
là
québec il ya loïc qui me dhiya loïc qui
me dit j'ai une connexion sur miss
picardie c'est la nièce de mon meilleur
pote donc apparemment je vais dire alors
on peut revoir miss picardie
on n'a pas encore la pac en vie on va
l'avoir très bien on attend alors mon
directeur miss miss midi pyrénées dont
cannes à petit col et en afrique au
nissan a pris connaît donc c'est un
essai qui ya lancé mme issoufou
midi-pyrénées anna friconnet nom est
traîné très sympa pour l'instant vous
restez à houla incarnez là je vous dis
ça au clair miss nord pas de calais
donatella meden voilà
tél c'est bon pour vous
en hiver c'est elle est là elle
s'était
dit sûr mais pas mon délire dont
vous avez vraiment de la merde dans les
yeux
la merde dans les yeux que la mère
d'autre part merci miss normandie yousra
askri cramatte sur son aile mais de la
fétis main ah ouais mais bon allez sur
la piste
merci merci miss nouvelle calédonie et
michelin 18 ans étudiante en licence de
langues étrangères ouais pour l'instant
vous restez tout sur vous voulez où vous
les fait défiler miss pays de la loire
line carvalho 20 ans étudiante en classe
préparatoire 1 m 78 n'ont pas volé
grande allée grand débat c'est bien
d'être miss picardie ciel donc
alors c'est sûr elle apparemment c'est
sur elle que j'ai une connexion ben
oui el garmaoui étude oto troisième
année de bachelor sport business
avec j'adore le sport bien dans le
business
c'est moderne
cipal à compiègne tu nous fais chier
quoi non mais tu t'emmerdes tout le
monde sait ça à qui je viens les
modernes ces deux qualités de vinnitsa
généralement une voix de fille là bas ça
peut être que kelis pas bernard montiel
oui évidemment une beauté n'a pas encore
eu en tant que nous fait vraiment
d'accord ils feraient ces 2021 sa très
belle carrière tels garmaoui ya lolita
ferrari
on a bien son nom miss poitou charentes
ahmed 71 agents d'accueil et de l'osce
et de gestion locative c'est important
dès l'âge de droit les sourcils comme ça
ça s'est dessinée mais là la même toit
là encore une fois il ya trop de faux
cils et c'est dommage parce qu'on
cherche un peu de la fraîcheur
miss provence ivan navarro oh oui oh oui
sous
le toit calme-toi il a même toit vous ça
vous change est un jeu bascule non parce
que les noms parce qu'il travaille et je
ne sais pas c'est une bonne nouvelle
pour elle
elle est née en grèce était miss réunion
dana virin s'en fout je crains pas je
m'en fous pas mal géré bascule
la gare de pas tomber
miss rhône alpes charlotte fort à 1073
étudièrent event émaner de communication
côté classique mais les beautés quand
même en iran qu'à ses yeux et enfin miss
tahiti
si tu as un buisson
well et chic du chic au barreau boire
maintenant en exclusivité les préférés
de chacun benjamin oui miss côte d'azur
benjamin miss côte d'azur à voir voilà
donc ses ailes pour vous la gagnante
gilles provence mais qu alcoa
va très bien valérie ile de france
tu as raison géraldine provence donc
prononça 2
provence c'est sa merci louis il avait
dit quand même réunion mais ce réunion
oui voila merci très bien mauvaises
observé vous est donné notre avis
delphine picardie oui d'un film dédé
picardie ah oui la raison picardie si
c'est ça c'est guillaume enfin guillaume
guillaume guillaume guillaume il a
choisi guillaume malle de loire
guillaume merci voilà bah merci et non
pas fous ils vont
chez moi on n'est pas chez votre
meilleur nord pas de calais voilà on
vous a présenté toutes les miss les
chéris moi je vais le dire aujourd'hui
je pense que la miss qui va gagner je
sens un truc c'est miss picardie le sang
je sens la picardie en plus je vais très
souvent chez picard
pense que c'est un c'est ça